Welcome back everyone this is my new daredevil
marvel video really for all the marvel netflix
characters punisher agents of shield too marvel
just made this big disney plus announcement they
even dropped a short trailer for it so we'll break
it all down because it's all part of a much larger
plan that they have for all the characters in
front of the types of marvel shows that they're
doing on disney plus everybody get hype if you're
new to the channel we're doing a giveaway for
those spider-man no way home blu-rays they just
announced that ton of extra toby maguire andrew
garfield matt murdock daredevil deleted scenes
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and let me know where you want to see all these
marvel netflix characters start showing up in the
mcu next real quick shout out to my friends at
hellofresh who asked to sponsor this video they
wanted me to tell you about their meal delivery
service most of you who have been watching
any of my videos following my channel for the last
several years always ask me if i ever have time to
sleep and the secret is that it's all just a lot
of time management wizardry and good nutrition
thanks to hellofresh with hellofresh you get
pre-proportioned ingredients and seasonal recipes
delivered straight to your doorstep you don't
have to waste any time going to the grocery store
trying to find everything or even coming up with
your own recipes hellofresh takes care of all that
for you they also help you cut down on food waste
their pre-proportioned ingredients means that they
give you exactly the right amount for everything
you need to make all your meals saving you time
and money if you go to hellofresh.com right now
and use the promo code pog emergency a16 you
can get 16 free meals and three surprise gifts
across six hello fresh boxes plus the shipping
for everything is free some of the free gifts are
appetizers desserts and some of the more premium
recipes so i'll put a link for that down in the
description below be sure to check them out so big
thing first you all probably saw in your feeds
this past week that netflix was getting rid of
all the marvel netflix shows daredevil jessica
jones luke cage iron fist the defenders punisher
that's because the agreement that marvel had with
netflix is over and they now have the ability to
bring all those to disney plus proper that's gonna
happen by the middle of march so if you're not
watching this video to like a week after i post
it the episodes for all those shows might be up
on disney plus already as part of this they're
also getting agents of shield back too they're
bringing that to disney plus if you didn't realize
they didn't have those episodes on disney plus yet
more on that at the end of the video when i talk
about what's canon now to the mcu and what's not
canon the bigger deal here though them bringing
the marvel netflix characters to disney plus is
that if you live in the united states or you've
lived in the united states the past couple years
the version of disney plus that you've had access
to only has family-friendly content like pg pg13
stuff pretty much every other country around
the world that has disney plus has a special
section of disney plus in the app with rated
r adult content or tvma whatever your country
calls adult content in all the marvel netflix
shows daredevil punisher jessica jones luke cage
iron fist the defenders were all rated r tvma the
reason this is a big deal now is because it just
means that disney plus is planning on doing more
adult content thankfully finally like it's not all
going to be pg content i think some of us heard
about the plans for upcoming shows big characters
fan favorite marvel characters and the thought
of them doing some of them as pg pg-13 kind of
hamstringing some of the stories which is kind
of sad like i've talked a lot about them doing
a new version of a daredevil series eventually
on disney plus but people were kind of upset
because they're like how do you do that as like a
pg-13 or pg series it'd be like the most watered
down version of daredevil ever please don't do
that marvel the fact that they're bringing the
original daredevil episodes to disney plus they're
not gonna put it somewhere else like hulu or some
other streaming service means that disney is not
afraid to do adult content so you don't have to
worry about them hamstringing any kind of future
revival series for any of the marvel netflix
characters moon knight is probably a good example
of that too it's going to be way more hardcore
than loki episodes wand division falcon and winter
soldier what if hawkeye there are a lot of marvel
characters out there that would make for amazing
tv series but aren't super family-friendly pg
content like there's no version of the punisher
that you could do as a pg even pg-13 series
i did a video a while ago too about marvel's
current plans for charlie cox's daredevil and
kingpin inside the mcu because they're sort of
the tip of the iceberg like they came back during
spider man no way home in hawkeye and they're the
tip of the iceberg for them sort of re-canonizing
or canonizing most of the marvel netflix stuff
most of those actors coming back in some form in
the future in the mcu not everybody but most
of them right now the plan just starts with
some of the daredevil characters in the next
couple of years mostly having them show up in
other people's disney plus series like daredevil
is supposed to be part of the she-hulk series
jessica jones kristen ritter rumored to come back
during that too daredevil kingpin and some of the
other daredevil netflix characters are supposed to
come back again during the echo series and that's
supposed to feel kind of like a daredevil season
4 unofficially in longer term like a couple years
down the road the scuttlebutt is i've mentioned
before marvel doing a full-blown daredevil disney
plus series revival with most of the characters
coming back like everybody gets new costumes like
daredevil will get a new daredevil costume when he
shows up as daredevil in the mcu like we saw him
as matt murdock during spider-man no way home the
next time he shows up we'll probably see him as
daredevil with a new daredevil costume but all
these characters will still have the same vibe
as they did during the netflix episodes
vincent d'onofrio even said during all
his interviews on the hawkeye series he was
playing the same version of kingpin from the
daredevil netflix series he had the exact same
cufflinks he was even wearing the same black
suit in one of those deleted scenes when you talk
about organized crime in the marvel universe and
you talk about the cd underbelly of new york city
there is one primary character that comes to mind
he said i want to bring you into the mcu and
i'm not going to say no to that like that's
pretty awesome but when they bring some of these
characters back like kingpin for example they did
the special featurette on disney plus that you've
probably seen the marvel producers said that they
wanted to do a slightly different version of
kingpin like they wanted to do more heavyset
version but they kind of changed their minds about
that so they wanted to tune some of the creative
behind his character but essentially he's the
same version from the daredevil netflix episodes
it'll be the same thing with all the other
marvel netflix characters pretty much the same
versions of the characters which is slight
creative retunings like different costumes
and it's not like they're going to come back
referencing every single thing that they ever did
in all those episodes so the biggest question
a lot of you have been asking me now the past
few days is does this mean that all the netflix
shows and agents of shield are now totally canon
100 percent to the mcu like are they bringing
everybody back inside the mcu now and the
answer is no not totally like they don't have big
plans to bring back iron fist anytime soon mike
coulter said that there are currently no plans
to bring back his version of luke cage right now
yes coulson did come back in the captain marvel
movie but that was because it took place in the
90s when he was younger and still alive in the
mcu before he'd been killed by loki during the
avengers movie they also just canonized hawkeye's
wife as the mcu version of mockingbird there was a
version of that character on agents of shield
played by adrian paliki so some of the mcu
versions of the characters from the shows will
be a little bit different what about recasting
some of the characters like iron fist wouldn't it
be weird if some of the characters are the same
and is trying to be canon but some of the actors
are different like you're telling me during the
events of luke cage when iron fist cameoed and
they teamed up for heroes for higher action it
was this other actor the whole time and not finn
jones but it was from the same universe from that
original show the simple way marvel kevin feige
solve problems like this is to totally dodge the
problem the easiest way to win that game is to not
play that game you won't have a problem in future
marvel phase 4 marvel phase 5 movies tv shows
if you just don't bring back every single one
of the characters like if they don't want to bring
back this version of iron fist in new episodes and
recasting would create too much confusion they'll
probably just not bring back iron fist at all
ever you can't have a continuity problem if you
never introduce another new version it's also kind
of the same thing with luke cage and punisher for
example mike coulter was great as that character
john bernthal was amazing as punisher marvel does
not have plans to recast luke cage or punish her
but if those actors are too busy filming other
shows of their movies and marvel doesn't have a
really great story to bring them back for marvel
will just not bring those characters back until
they find that opportunity so that's why you're
seeing the daredevil characters come back right
now but some of the other netflix characters
probably won't come back for a long time so
technically yes most of the marvel netflix stuff
is canon to the mcu now via all this daredevil
stuff that they just did in spider man no way home
and then during the hawkeye series but a lot of
the other characters won't officially became like
100 canon until you physically see them appear on
screen in a new project with the marvel studios
logo on it if you do have any specific questions
about what's canon and what's not about any of
the characters of the shows post them in the
comments and i'll try to address them but coming
up later this month marvel's moon knight is like
the next big thing that's happening i'll be doing
full episode videos for that just like i did for
loki hawkeye wandavision all the other marvel
disney plus series oscar isaac is going to kill
it he's going to be amazing the batman movie is
also out this week so be sure to go see it when
you have the chance congrats to andrew you're
the giveaway winner from my batman review video
please email me on the about page of my channel
so i can get your details everyone click here
for the batman movie review video get hype and
click here for my doctor strange 2 iron man video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!